[Musique]
c'est effectivement une exposition
inhabituelle sur les grilles du sénat
mais parce que le 80e anniversaire de la
rafle du vel d'hiv appelait une
initiative exceptionnelle du sénat
nous avons voulu que cette exposition
que ces portraits soit sur les grilles
du sénat de façon publique en libre
accès de manière à interpeller les
passants et qu'ils puissent ensuite
s'emparer de leur histoire pour pouvoir
la transmettre
tout a commencé par la rencontre du crif
avec luigi toscane aux artistes pour la
paix de l'unesco nous avons été captivé
par son travail et avons eu envie de
monter un projet exceptionnel à
l'occasion du 80e anniversaire de la
rafle du vel d'hiv et de l'année 1942
nous avons rencontré quarante deux
survivants de la shoah partout en france
chaque rencontre est accompagné de
beaucoup d'émotion nous avons écouté
parler du passé et du présent de leur
vécu pendant la guerre mais également de
tout ce qu'ils ont accompli après tout
au long de leur vie les témoignages
publiés sur le site dédié à l'exposition
raconte ce moment des changes
[Musique]
80 ans et nous avons l'impression que
aujourd'hui ces regards vivant nous
interpelle ils nous interpellent par
rapport aux valeurs qui doivent être les
nôtres ces témoignages là c'est aussi
tous ceux qui sont assassinés parce que
juif au fond nous ne devons pas
détourner nos regards je crois que c'est
important à nous politiques que nous
portions à la fois cette mémoire pour
témoigner d'hier pour aujourd'hui
ces personnes qui sont en photo sur les
grilles qui ont survécu à l'horreur et
qui vivent depuis qu'ils ont tous un âge
très avancé mais qui ont encore beaucoup
de vitalité c'est aussi une marque
d'espoir
le défi qui est lancé à tous ceux qui
vont visiter cette exposition c'est de
saisir le témoin et d'être eux mêmes les
témoins des témoins c'est là tout
l'objectif que nous poursuivons
[Musique]